ici à Gien je vais rencontrer un artiste
un cinéaste François zabaletta qui a
créé un laboratoire éphémère afin de
partager à travers l'art toute forme de
culture et moi personnellement ça me
touche ça m'inspire ça me rend pour être
j'ai envie de vous dire déjà essayé déjà
échoué peu importe et c'est encore
échoue encore
quelle aspiration
ouais mais non les gens vont
[Musique]
du plus loin que je me souvienne je n'ai
jamais eu faim du plus loin que je me
souvienne je n'ai jamais eu faim
on dirait le musée Grévin un peu du plus
loin que je me souvienne je n'ai jamais
eu faim tu as toujours mangé à ta faim
j'aurais pu manger à ma faim mais je ne
mangeais pas je me suis fait avoir je ne
voulais pas manger et dans le spectacle
je décris ce que c'est qu'à hauteur
d'enfant quelqu'un qui arrête de manger
un truc qui me fait flipper je vais m'en
écarter un peu d'ailleurs alors ça c'est
un crâne je faisais partie de ces gens
qui se demandaient ce qu'il foutait là
et qui pensait qu'il mourrait jeune et
donc pour moi c'était très important de
se souvenir de la mort la mortalité que
je pense avoir provisoirement vaincu
puisque je suis encore vivant
[Musique]
les forces du mal
ce lieu là 600 mètres carrés pour
s'amuser pour faire des spectacles pour
parler de culture comment c'était venu
cette envie cette idée et comment tu
l'as trouvé cet endroit et c'était notre
endroit à mon mari et moi mon mari est
commissaire priseur et on a commencé en
2017 parce que je voyais Le Pen arrivé à
l'Élysée et pour moi c'était évidemment
pas possible donc j'ai réuni les amis
les intellectuels que je connaissais
dans la région et on a décidé de faire
un lieu de création exigeante mais aussi
du mécénat culturel donc on offre cette
salle à des gens qui ont des projets des
gens qui ont des problèmes d'insertion
sociale qui ont quelque chose à raconter
et pas de lieu
quand est-ce que tu t'es dit je vais
être cinéaste sur le tard j'ai réalisé
un long métrage qui s'appelle la vie
intermédiaire j'avais pas d'argent je
connaissais personne j'ai envoyé le film
à Cannes totalement dans l'inconscient
c'est le film a été pris et je n'ai
jamais arrêté depuis bon alors François
j'ai une autre question mais qu'est-ce
que tu fais là bah écoute il y a 600 m²
j'ai envie d'écouter le terrain moi
alors ma position est étrange mais c'est
parce que ça c'est un peu une position
de danse tu vois est-ce qu'il y a aussi
de la danse oui il y aura de la danse
contemporaine au printemps je vais pas
vous étiez là vous êtes depuis le début
on parle de spectacle très triste est-ce
qu'il y a aussi des spectacles amusants
de bonne humeur de joie de vivre ici pas
vraiment mais a priori je suis pas
contre il va y avoir des récitales
[Musique]
faut pas me dire ça deux fois
votre honneur
faut savoir qui est le public qui vient
assister aux représentations ici on a la
chance ici d'avoir tous les publics
toujours rêvé d'être jugé c'est comme
dans les séries américaines
mais je t'entends pas viens
c'est sûr que dans l'armoire tu
m'entends pas
François tu es prêt oui
j'ai perdu c'est pas possible d'ailleurs
question François pourquoi l'écran blanc
c'est une magnifique métaphore de la
réinvention de soi on se regarde sur un
écran blanc où tout est encore à
réinventer et bien François on va créer
une œuvre ensemble l'ombre câlins
merci mon François merci à toi et oui
c'est ça comme une des câlins
l'affection et la tendresse
qui sont les caresses énormes